i'll just throw it to you guys right now
can can you actually scott you know
you're working on this
can you can you name one person from
each party that you think is actually
trying to do good i would say
on the right i think ted cruz and josh
hawley are trying to do good
i would put stock in them as
good candidates on the right side
on the left let's say all of congress
too even the house not just senators i
love matt gates
yeah give me some gates and in fact i
i wanted him to run against marco rubio
and primary him but he's not going to do
that in florida unfortunately
um desantis look i judge a person
not their talk but their walk if you are
results driven if you were actually
focused on accomplishments if you were
actually writing
bills and passing legislation and
preventing unconstitutional measures
like the mask
mandates desantis would be my boy
and uh he's he's doing great he's great
you think he'll be vp with trump 2020
you know i want him to stay as governor
desantis you're doing a great job stay
as governor please we need you to stay
in there
and you know he's young he's young and
he's got young kids and he's a wonderful
wife
i could see him being definitely a
presidential contender for the future
but wait can you name at least one
democrat you think
is trying to do good that's
a hard question no well it's hard
because you know
um i mean look at look at kristin cinema
for example i know the progressives
they're really angry with her
because she she was this was
this progressive fighter that was
fighting for 15
and look what she voted against the
other day she was one of the eight
democratic senators that voted against
the fight for 15.
so i don't really want to primary her
i'm not i'm not a fan of of
the 15 minimum wage oh i'm not either i
think there are other ways we have to
solve this problem i i will say this i
certainly want people to make more than
fifty dollars yes
and i think there's a lot of issues
around minimum wage
no i don't i wouldn't uh personally i'm
not a fan of cinema because
she was fighting for 15 and then as soon
as she got the power she said later
i'm i'm like how many politicians we
have are honestly saying here's what i
want to do and i'll do it and then they
do
it's easy to point out many republicans
it's easy you know
ted cruz holly far from perfect but i do
believe like they're fighting for what
they said they were going to fight for
yes rand paul is the easiest oh yes like
rand paul is probably
like one of the pardon me doctor i
forgot right
on the left i can give credit to rokhana
um because he he called out pelosi when
she was obstructing covert relief
but it really is hard to find democrats
who are like i'm going to do this trust
me and then doing it not even aoc
she's like i'm gonna i'm gonna challenge
nancy pelosi and then vote for her every
single time
there is one gentleman i forget his name
but
he continues to primary debbie wasserman
schultz
in florida canova yes i give respect to
canova
because he seems that he's been
consistent in his messaging
and just he won't lock in step with the
democratic party just because of debbie
wasserman so i give credit to
anova we had tulsi yeah that's what i
was thinking and she
she was the real deal yeah it was like i
can't be part of this joke anymore
and basically for whatever i'm going now
because it's
way more effective to change culture
there was a a joke the left was saying
they said um
until c gabbard was was assigned
republican at birth
making a joke about her and it's like
she's such a progressive she's like in
favor of gun control
she's disagree she's anti-nuclear power
like at least in her policy positions
i've criticized uh her position for that
i disagree with them
but you could clearly see that she was
at least attempting to cross the aisle
and shake hands and be
like let's work together and she abstain
i believe she abstained from impeachment
right she was the one of the few who was
like i'm not getting involved and there
were like two other democrats that said
no i think so
jeff van drew i'd shout out for the
democratic party but he quit he joined
the republicans
interesting yeah you know lately rashida
tulabe said a few things on twitter that
i
was very surprised and happy to see i'll
give her a shout out i
i supporting human rights and the right
to freedom of speech i don't know it's a
lot of media spin so it's hard to say
that like she's the real deal but i'm
i'm really happy for whatever you know
what
i'm going to absolutely say i will say
rishi to tilley i disagree with her yeah
a lot of things she's like
but she's consistent right so she voted
against the omnibus bill
that was like a lot of this foreign
spending and bloat for reasons that you
know i probably don't agree with
and a lot of our policies don't agree
with i'm just looking for someone who's
going to be like here's what i want to
do and i will do it
i look at almost every single politician
and they're like if you vote for me
i'm going to get into congress and i'm
going to end this blockade i'm going to
fight for kitchen table issues like the
economy and jobs
and then 31 democrats get in and the
first thing they do is thank you for
letting me
impeach him impeachment i don't care
about your insurance i want to impeach
trump
that's what they did that's why i'm
sorry man when
you it was 31 districts right they they
flipped from 2016 to 18. wow
you got these moderate it was more than
that i think it was like 44.
wow whoa in 2018 but it was still fewer
than the 63 that we flipped in 2010
under president obama right so they want
to make it seem like it was this
massive big landslide no the biggest was
in 2010 under president obama just yeah
well so you had these democrats
promising to fight for you
yes so so people were sitting there
watching republicans in 2016
have the house the senate and you know
the presidency
not a whole lot got done which is
amazing the republicans have the power
but they don't want to do it because the
establishment doesn't like trump
and so then these people say give me
something different i'm sick of this
culture war stuff
and along came these moderates i'm doing
air quotes and they were like if you
vote for us
we will fight for healthcare and jobs we
don't care about trump we don't care
about his naughty words
we're gonna try and work with the
republicans to get you something
something tangible
and then what happened right away nancy
pelosi walked right up to each and every
one who won and said now you'll do as i
say and they said yes ma'am
and so then they went all in on
impeachment there was nothing
substantive
and you know if it were me i'd say no
i understand mitch mcconnell is
obstructing the bills the house is
sending because there is a break this
happens it happens in politics
the senate will be republican the house
will be democrat and nothing gets done
but i still would not entertain this
ridiculous bs that was this this
fake impeachment for what reason that's
what we got i don't know vehemence
it was weird it seemed like an emotional
response i i
from the outside it looked so ridiculous
the impeachment yeah
and then look at going back to what
we're talking about with cuomo
how like the news was being held back
the press wouldn't report it
and then only after the election did it
get released same with kovat the numbers
went down 55 they're like covenant
numbers are down 55 percent now that
trump's out of office then it was
a week later now it's 60 and then a
couple weeks now it's 70 percent
down now that trump's out office they
weren't saying that now that trump's out
of office but
but but they weren't holding that news
back that news just happened after trump
i'm saying i'm saying quite literally
you had the hunter biden story
suppressed
and then after the election oh that
whole thing was true by the way you had
the cuomo nursing home numbers
and then they suppress it and then after
the election oh by the way cuomo's
you know killed these people then you
had impeachment officer siknik in the
capital riots
oh he was killed by a fire extinguisher
and then after impeachment
oh that wasn't true the time news
article about fortification of elections
could have come out before the election
it had been happening since 2019 they
knew about it yep
they waited until after the election
well of course of course yeah the shadow
the shadow campaign the fortification
they called it
they they you know i looked at that
article and i'm like
always returned to the scene of the
crime they wanted everybody to know i
mean that figuratively youtube calm down
they wanted everybody to know the work
they were doing to fortify the election
hard work man as i describe it they the
oceans elevened trump
you know the rules were changed a year
in advance mail-in voting all of these
big drives
there was one woman in texas who got
arrested for for ballot harvesting but
you had you know
votes in the park or whatever was
constant a lot of things that were they
were challenged and the supreme court
just said no we don't care about none of
this we're not going to hear it
and then clarence thomas was like if
we're not going to hear it before
we're not going to hear it during and
we're not going to hear it after when
will anyone get resolution on any of
this stuff
no i guess you won't so anyway this
whole thing started by asking
scott because you're you're going after
these america last politicians to be
able to name
somebody and it's like how why is it
that it's easy to name a handful of
conservatives that are doing what they
say they want to do republicans
and it's so difficult to find democrats
that are you know doing what they say
look i think you need only look at hr
one that wants to it's this voting bill
they call it voting
rights bill or it's actually just a
voter reform bill they want to lower the
voting age to 16.
that's that's as low information as you
can go for a political party
the democrats say we just want more
people to be able to vote and i'm like
i'd love it if everyone
you know of a certain age had the right
had the ability to vote
but i also think if you're if that's
your goal
you really want low information voters
like people who don't know what's going
on
you know what i mean yeah stupid people
are allowed to vote don't get me wrong
i'm just saying
it's indicative of what the party
represents i would have voted for
whoever my parents told me to vote for
if i was 16.
right right yes you probably i think if
you want more voters you should make it
so that felons can vote
because i do think that's a right and i
think that once you've paid your debt to
society by going to prison
if you want voters get the felon vote i
agree
i i think that people who serve their
their time and debt to society should
have their
they shouldn't lose rights for this
right they should it's like state by
state
here's your gun and here's your vote
have a nice day exactly yeah nah but we
and
it's really crazy you get a felony like
you're you're a second-class citizen at
this point
that's too bad and i i think that's
wrong i do i think we're supposed to
have
rehabilitation not retribution people
who go to prison
we're supposed to be like you you
promise to do better all right okay
come on out here's your job here are
your rights
you can participate same as everybody
else if you do it again you go back to
prison if it's already illegal why do we
need to do these things
i'm not a fan of certain like
non-violent felonies for sure like if
it's like
repeating violent felonies maybe maybe
you gotta remove them from society for a
while but
violence right you you get you know
maximum security prisons and things like
that
but uh yeah especially non-violent stuff
which is another
i'll say it's a disappointment i was
hoping that trump on the way out would
take bolder action
in terms of pardoning people and he
didn't and he pardoned that that you
know corrupt was it the mayor from
detroit or whatever so
what was your thoughts on trump
generally
well i mean today i put out a tweet
talking about policies that i
stand for you know i want fair trade
not free trade and i want lower
corporate tax
and i want to secure the border
and you know a lot of the things that i
was tweeting about
uh people were like well those are
president trump's policies
and it was just interesting to see how
every single one of those
that he was working towards or had
accomplished
and uh and that's what i think the
future of the republican party is
and endless wars he put a cap
on insulin prices what's the first thing
that president uh biden does he removes
the cap
now insulin is skyrocketing during a
pandemic i mean how heartless can you be
uh to our community facing diabetes that
you're going to
skyrocket the price of insulin and
uh it was just really interesting that
the things that i put out were
so non-controversial like for example
let's stop giving funding and foreign
aid
to countries that say death to america
or hate us or who are having
camps for terrorism bomb
training classes you know why are we
funding
those countries can anyone answer me
that question
and why are we not focusing on building
our infrastructure making sure that our
schools
are funded and not worse than japan why
are we
rebuilding china why are we rebuilding
the rest of the world
not investing in our infrastructure and
i think if we move forward
with those policies will have a very
successful right
what um you said fair trade which
sounded kind of interesting how would
you define that
for example oh i know i love talking
about this issue i am not
a free trader i think free trade
is fool's trade for example why
am i going to allow another country like
china to impose a
tariff on my products while
i don't impose a tariff back on them i
just think that's
the most asinine thing
ever that i'm going to allow you to
steal from me
and basically i'm going to reward you
for stealing from me
by then not imposing a tariff back on
you i just think that is fool's trade
and so if you do it to my products
i'm gonna do it back to you and i just
think it was so
also asinine that for the longest time
america had a
higher corporate tax than other
countries
why not make ourselves competitive and
say wait a second if we lower the
corporate tax
maybe more businesses are going to come
to our country as opposed to leaving the
country to go to
a corporate tax haven overseas and i
just think
we need to make things more common sense
and just go
wow let's go to the lowest common
denominator to make things more
competitive to bring more business to
america combine those issues right joe
biden was in favor of free trade
agreements
he was in favor of increasing the
minimum wage and increasing corporate
tax rates
what will those three things do okay if
i can set up a factory in china
and i'd pay a lower tax and a lower wage
to my employees i save a bunch of money
and then i can send all my products back
to the us for free
as an extraction it is it is it is the
most insane combination of pockets and
the american workers will be too
expensive to hire because they're all
making a gigantic
wage at minimum so you gotta hire
outside the country it'll drive american
salaries and wages down
it'll force them down and we see this
happen okay these free trade agreements
did this
why it's why bernie sanders in 2016 was
popular and trump because bernie was
saying the same things
open borders is a koch brothers proposal
these free trade agreements right and he
got smeared the world socialist website
called bernie sanders a capitalist
national
free trade is dangerous they called him
that it was hilarious free trade doesn't
lead to freedom it leads to corporate
slavery
like if you allow corporations to trade
unfetteredly they do things like the
what was it the um trans-pacific
partnership
where they're basically giving
corporations the ability to sue
american citizens to sue our government
for like
defamation or for what they would call
like uh it was an extraction
it was like hollowing out the united
states the american workers were getting
left behind
small small towns were falling apart and
that's why people
just were screaming i'm mad as hell and
i can't take it anymore
and then bernie you know it's
unfortunate that bernie sold out
and he went totally establishment and
changed his tune from fighting for the
working class to
you know white privilege and social
justice because that i guess he became
rich and he didn't want to let it go
yeah oh there was the in the
trans-pacific partnership there was a
clause called the uh investor state
dispute settlement that said that if uh
american citizens were to discriminate
is the actual word they use and say i
don't want to buy malaysian oil
that the the malaysian oil companies
could sue the government for
discrimination against them and then we
as taxpayers would have to pay this
corporation's
lawsuit i think i think one of the
reasons we saw the economy do so well in
2019 was a combination of trump's
policies
he was you know we saw in michigan the
auto factory started coming back
because well now the famous line from
michael moore
michael moore said trump walks into this
into this executive
executive office or whatever with these
these wigs and says
i will put a 30 tariff on your vehicles
if you make them overseas and no one
will ever buy your car again
and michael moore was like no one ever
said that to these people
to these to these these fat cats who are
sending the jobs overseas for dirt wages
for
you got to think about what these
companies do they don't want to pay
health care benefits
they don't want to pay a living wage so
what happens you give a good free trade
agreement
and they can hire some people in china
for pennies on the dollar with no rights
and then sell that car back to the
american people but guess what the
american people
are slowly losing their access and
wealth so the the resources of the
americans are being stripped away
the only thing that really props all of
this up and this is where it gets
more dastardly before i start i'll say
scott your response like your your your
the things you talk about is a sound
responsible american policy of americans
working hard and earning what they
you know what they work for right now
it's the petro dollar
it's it's joe biden basically being like
it doesn't matter how much money we
print because we'll shoot anybody who
tries to trade oil off the dollar
so we can print all the money in the
world and we don't got to export
anything other than
killing people going to other countries
blowing them up you combine donald
trump's policies
and then you look at why the
establishment hated him so much
abraham accords historic peace
agreements in the middle east
yet there was there was an increase in
drone bombings he did get rid of isis
though
so trump was not perfect in the middle
east but we weren't seeing the
escalation in syria we were seeing
de-escalation across the board and these
peace agreements meant
we are less likely to go and blow up
people who defy the petro dollar
and trump was like americans can work
hard and earn their living
and then you have the the establishment
elites going
we have to work oh no no i'd rather just
shoot people
military industrial complexes like but
who we sell our bombs to
so all of these status quo establishment
people were just like
dude it was so easy to extract wealth
and then the military industrial complex
was like it was so easy
just selling bombs can we just go back
to pointing the american gun
at other countries who refuse to use the
petrodollar again then we don't gotta
work
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you